Traductor: Ciro Gomez
Revisor: Emma Gon
Echa un vistazo por la ventana,
ponte tus gafas si acaso las usas.
Tal vez quieras utilizar un par
de binoculares, también,
o una lupa.
Ahora, ¿qué ves?
Bueno, sea lo que sea,
no son las múltiples
capas de vidrio
justo delante de ti.
Pero ¿te has preguntado
cómo algo tan sólido
puede ser tan invisible?
Para entenderlo,
tenemos que entender lo
que es el vidrio en realidad,
y de dónde viene.
Todo comienza en
la corteza terrestre,
donde están dos de
los elementos más comunes,
silicio y oxígeno.
Estos reaccionan juntos para
formar dióxido de silicio,
cuyas moléculas se arreglan
en una forma cristalina regular
conocida como cuarzo.
El cuarzo se encuentra
comúnmente en la arena,
donde a menudo se conforma
la mayoría de los granos
y es el ingrediente principal en
la mayoría de tipos de vidrio.
Por supuesto, probablemente
has notado que ese vaso
no está hecho de múltiples
pequeños trozos de cuarzo,
Los bordes de
los granos rígidos formados
y los pequeños defectos
en la estructura cristalina
reflejan y dispersan
la luz.
Pero cuando el cuarzo
se calienta lo suficiente,
la energía adicional hace
que las moléculas vibren
hasta que se rompen los lazos
que los mantienen juntos
y se convierten en un líquido,
del mismo modo que
el hielo se derrite en agua.
A diferencia del agua,
el dióxido de silicio líquido
no retorna a un cristal
sólido cuando se enfría.
En cambio, conforme
las moléculas pierden energía,
son cada vez
menos capaces de
moverse a una
posición ordenada,
y el resultado es lo que
se llama un sólido amorfo.
Un material sólido con la estructura
caótica de un líquido,
que permite que las moléculas
llenen los vacíos libremente.
Esto hace uniforme
la superficie del vidrio
a nivel microscópico,
permitiendo a la luz golpearlo
sin ser dispersada.
Pero esto no explica
por qué la luz es capaz
de atravesar el cristal
en lugar de ser absorbida como
con la mayoría de los sólidos.
Por eso, tenemos
que ir hasta el fondo,
a nivel subatómico.
Quizá sepas que un átomo
consiste en un núcleo
con electrones orbitando
alrededor de él,
pero te puede
sorprender saber
parte es espacio vacío.
De hecho, si un átomo fuera del
tamaño de un estadio deportivo,
el núcleo sería como un
solo guisante en el centro,
mientras que los electrones
serían como granos de arena
en los asientos exteriores.
Esto deja un montón de espacio
para que la luz atraviese
sin golpear a alguna
de estas partículas.
Entonces la verdadera
pregunta no es,
¿por qué el cristal
es transparente,
cuando no todos los materiales
son transparentes?
La respuesta tiene que ver con
los diferentes niveles de energía
que pueden tener
los electrones en un átomo.
Piensa en esto como
diferentes filas de asientos
en las gradas del estadio.
Un electrón es asignado inicialmente
a sentarse en una cierta fila,
pero podría saltar
a una fila mejor,
si solo tuviera la energía.
Por suerte
absorber uno de
esos fotones de luz
que pasan a través
del átomo puede darles
justo la energía que
el electrón necesita.
Pero hay una treta.
La energía del fotón
tiene que ser
la cantidad correcta
para llevar un electrón
a la fila siguiente.
De lo contrario, solo
dejará pasar al fotón,
y es lo que pasa
con el cristal,
las filas están
tan separadas
que un fotón de luz visible
no puede proporcionar suficiente
energía para que un electrón
salte entre ellas.
Los fotones de luz
ultravioleta, por otro lado,
dan la cantidad
justa de energía,
y son absorbidos,
por lo cual no puedes
broncearte a través de vidrio.
Esta asombrosa propiedad
de ser ambos cosas,
sólido y transparente,
ha dado al cristal muchos usos
a lo largo de los siglos.
Desde ventanas que
dejan pasar la luz
manteniendo afuera
los elementos,
a lentes que
nos permiten ver tanto
los vastos mundos más allá
de nuestro planeta,
como las pequeñas
cosas que nos rodean.
Es difícil imaginar
la civilización moderna sin cristal.
Y sin embargo, para
un material tan importante
rara vez pensamos en
el cristal y su impacto.
Es precisamente porque
la más importante
y útil cualidad del vidrio es
ser invisible y
sin rasgos distintivos,
que a menudo olvidamos
que está aún ahí.